>> LIBERALS CONTINUING THEIR
ILLEGAL MELTDOWN OVER ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS SHOWING UP IN THEIR
RITZY TOWNS.
IT TOOK ONLY TWO DAYS AFTER
ARRIVING FOR MIGRANTS TO BE
SHIPPED AWAY FROM MARTHA'S
VINEYARD EVEN THOUGH THE ISLAND
IS FLUSH WITH CASH AND PLENTY OF
BEDS.
TURNS OUT DEMOCRATS DON'T
PRACTICE WHAT THEY'RE PREACHING,
LOBBING ACCUSATIONS, ACCUSING
REPUBLICANS OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING
AND CRIMES AGAINST HUMANITY.
THE RED STATE GOVERNORS ARE AS
DEFIANT AS OVER.
>> THEY WANT OPEN BORDERS.
THEY WANT YOU TO DEAL WITH THE
OPEN BORDERS, BUT WANT TO BE
IMMUNE FROM THE CONSEQUENCES OF
THESE POLICIES.
>> NOW TEXAS IS SAYING, WE'RE
FIGHTING BACK.
WE'RE GOING TO SEND THEM TO YOUR
NEIGHBORHOOD.
WE'RE GOING TO KEEP THOSE BUSES
COMING UNTIL FINALLY THIS
ADMINISTRATION WAKES UP.
>> MEANWHILE KAMALA HARRIS MIGHT
WANT TO LOOK IN THE MIRROR AFTER
MAKING THIS ACCUSATION AGAINST
REPUBLICANS.
>> I THINK THE HEIGHT OF
IRRESPONSIBILITY.
FRANKLY A DERELICTION OF DUTY
WHEN YOU ARE AN ELECTED LEADER
TO PLAY THOSE KINDS OF GAMES
WITH HUMAN LIFE AND HUMAN
BEINGS.
IF YOU THINK THERE'S A PROBLEM,
BE PART OF THE SOLUTION.
>> ONE BORDER STATE, DEMOCRATS
TELLING KAMALA HOW IT REALLY IS.
>> THE BORDER IS NOT SECURE.
LOOK, WE GET THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
ALONG THE BORDER, YOU KNOW, FROM
6,000 TO 8,000 PEOPLE A DAY.
THEY'RE RELEASING PEOPLE, AND WE
CAN SEND YOU PICTURES AND VIDEOS
OF WHAT'S HAPPENING IN DEL RIO,
THE VALLEY, EL PASO AND OTHER
PLACES.
PEOPLE ARE COMING IN.
>> HUMAN TRAFFICKING, JESSICA?
REALLY?
THAT'S A QUESTION.
>> OH, REALLY?
I DON'T KNOW HOW THOSE LAWSUITS
ARE GOING TO GO, BUT I WATCHED
THIS HAPPEN.
THE PEOPLE OF MARTHA'S VINEYARD,
NOT THE FANCY SUMMER FOLKS, THE
AVERAGE MEDIAN INCOME IS AROUND
$70,000, THEY'RE A MAJORITY
MINORITY ENCLAVE, EXCEPT IN THE
SUMMER WHEN RICH PEOPLE SHOW UP
AND IGNORE ALAN DERSHOWITZ.
EVERYONE GOT THAT JOKE.
>> YES.
IT WAS AN ELITIST JOKE.
>> WHATEVER.
>> DON'T GET DISTRACTED.
JUST POWER THROUGH IT.
>> IT'S ONLY MONDAY.
I DIDN'T SEE THE ARGUMENT THAT
THEY WERE BEHAVING, YOU KNOW,
NOT COMMENSURATE WITH THEIR
VALUES.
>> THEY DEPORTED THEM IN TWO
DAYS.
>> THEY SENT THEM WHERE THEY
WERE SUPPOSED TO GOING, WHICH IS
BOSTON.
I KNOW THERE'S DISPUTE ABOUT
PAMPHLETS PROMISING THEM OF
EIGHT MONTHS OF CASH ASSISTANCE,
JOB TRAINING, HOUSING, ETC., BUT
THESE PEOPLE WERE TOLD THEY WERE
GOING TO MASSACHUSETTS.
>> ISN'T THE VINEYARD IN
MASSACHUSETTS?
>> YES, BUT THAT'S NOT WHAT THEY
WERE TOLD.
>> IT'S LIKE BEING SENT TO NEW
YORK AND WINDING UP IN LONG
ISLAND.
>> LET ME POWER THROUGH.
>> SORRY.
>> THE PERFORMANCE OF PRACTICE
JOKES ON OUR ENEMIES, THAT'S A
CRAPPY PLACE TO BE.
I'VE SEEN HOW HAPPY PEOPLE
ARE --
>> WHY IS IT A JOKE?
YOU WANTED THE MIGRANTS.
>> IT'S NOT A JOKE.
THE PEOPLE ARE COMING INTO THE
COUNTRY ILLEGALLY.
THE PRESIDENT HAS FLOWN OVER 900
FLIGHTS OF THE ILLEGALS INTO THE
INTERIOR OF THE UNITED STATES.
HE DOESN'T NOTIFY THE PEOPLE,
LIKE IN WESTCHESTER COUNTY,
WHERE I LIVE.
THE AIRPORT IS A MILE AND A HALF
FROM WHERE I LIVE.
I KNOW COPS.
THEY TELL ME EVERY TIME THEY FLY
THEM IN THE DARK OF NIGHT SO NO
ONE SEES THEM.
DON'T ACT LIKE IF WE DON'T OFFER
THEM A JOB, GIVE THEM THE
ABILITY TO GET TRAINED FOR A
JOB, WE'RE DOING SOMETHING
WRONG.
I DON'T BELIEVE THAT THERE'S ANY
PROBLEM.
THERE'S NO KIDNAPPING.
THERE'S NO HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
IT'S A JOKE.
THAT IS FORCED.
THEY CAME HERE VOLUNTARILY.
THEY FORCED THEIR WAY, IF YOU
WANT TO TALK ABOUT FORCING
COERCION.
BY THE WAY, THE FACT THAT
MARTHA'S VINEYARD IS $70,000 A
YEAR AVERAGE INCOME, WHAT DO YOU
THINK THOSE SOUTHERN TOWNS ARE
THAT ARE BEING OVERRUN AT THE
BORDER OR THE RANCHERS WHO CAN'T
AFFORD TO RANCH ANYMORE BECAUSE
THE WHOLE TERRAIN OF THEIR RANCH
IS DESTROYED.
YOU KNOW WHAT, THE LIBERALS ARE
THE ONES WHO DO ALL THE TALKING
AND DO ALL THE COMPLAINING.
THEY TALK THE TALK.
THEY DON'T WALK THE WALK.
>> YEAH.
GREG, YOU'RE RIGHT, JUDGE.
LIKE THEY BREAK INTO THE
COUNTRY, BREAKING OUR LAWS.
THEY DON'T GET TO -- I WANT A
FLIGHT TO MIAMI BEACH.
YOU DON'T GET TO PICK AND
CHOOSE.
>> UNITED STATES IS THE UNITED
STATES.
THEY'RE HAPPY TO BE HERE.
>> RIGHT.
>> I DON'T BLAME THEM.
IT'S THE GREATEST PLACE IN THE
WORLD.
WHETHER IT'S THAT ISLAND I'M NOT
ALLOWED IN, OR ANYWHERE FOR THAT
MATTER.
THE REPUBLICANS SUCCEEDED IN
DOING WHAT THE DEMOCRATS AND
MEDIA ALWAYS SAY THEY WANT, A
CONVERSATION, RIGHT?
WHENEVER WE WOULD TALK ABOUT A
POLICY, AND TALK ABOUT LAW
ENFORCEMENT, OR JUSTICE, OR WE
HAVE TO FOLLOW THE RULES, THEY'D
GO, WE REALLY NEED TO HAVE
CONVERSATION.
SO NOW YOU HAVE A CONVERSATION.
THE ONLY WAY YOU CAN GET THE
CONVERSATION WAS TO SHAME AND
EXPOSE THE LIBERALS FOR THEIR
PHONY COMPASSION.
DON'T GET MAD OVER THE ISSUE.
DON'T GET MAD ABOUT THE PEOPLE
CALLING ATTENTION TO THE ISSUE.
'CAUSE AFTER ALL, WE'RE JUST
RAISING AWARENESS.
RAISING AWARENESS IS, LIKE, THE
GREATEST THING LIBERALS HAVE
EVER WANTED TO DO FROM THE
BEGINNING OF TIME.
WHAT WE'RE SEEING RIGHT HERE IS
NOT IN MY BACKYARD, UNLESS
YOU'RE TRIMMING THE HEDGES.
THEN WE LOVE YOU, BUT I'M SO
GLAD THE LEAVE BLOWER IS SO LOUD
SO I DON'T HAVE TO TALK TO YOU.
NO, YOU CAN'T USE THE BATHROOM.
YOU CAN'T HAVE ANY WATER EITHER.
WE LOVE OUR MIGRANTS, DON'T WE?
YEAH, YOU RICH ENTITLED FREAK.
YOU PANICKED OVER 50 MIGRANTS
COMING OVER.
WHEN THEY'RE LEAVING, YOU LEARN
TWO WORDS, ONE OF THEM ADIOS, SO
YOU CAN HUG THEM ON THE WAY OUT.
THAT WAS SO COMPASSIONATE.
KAMALA, WHAT THE GOVERNORS DID,
WHAT THE DEMOCRATIC MAYORS,
INCLUDING THE DEMOCRATIC MAYOR
OF EL PASO, DID WHAT SHE
COULDN'T DO.
THEY MOVED THE BALL DOWN THE
FIELD.
THIS IS SOMETHING SHE WOULDN'T
HAVE THE BRAVERY OR THE
INTELLIGENCE TO DO, BECAUSE
SHE'S LAZY, TO QUOTE THE JUDGE.
THESE ARE THE SAME PEOPLE, YOU
KNOW, WHO VOLUNTEER FOR ONE DAY
AT THE SOUP KITCHEN IN 2015, AND
THEY STILL BRING IT UP.
THEY GO, OH, YEAH, YOU KNOW
WHAT, IT WAS THANKSGIVING.
IT WAS SO GREAT.
MEANWHILE FOR THE REST OF THEIR
LEAVES, THEY SMEAR REPUBLICANS
FOR BIG BIGOTS, SMEAR BORDER
AGENTS FOR DOING THEIR JOB.
THEY'RE AN EMBARRASSMENT.
AN ABSOLUTE EMBARRASSMENT.
MY FAVORITE STORY OF THE YEAR,
AND IT AIN'T NO PRACTICAL JOKE
WHEN YOU MOVE THE BALL DOWN THE
FIELD, YOU MASTERED THE ART OF
THE PROP, THE HANDS UP DON'T
SHOOT THAT NEVER HAPPENED,
RIGHT?
USING EVERY CRIMINAL DEATH,
EVERY SUSPECT DEATH, AS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR REFORM.
DON'T LET A CRIES GO TO WASTE,
YOU WOULD SCREAM.
HERE'S OUR CRISIS.
WE'RE NOT LETTING IT GO TO
WASTE.
TOO BAD.
SORRY.
>> WELL SAID, GREG.
>> COFFEE.
>> THEY BROUGHT IN THE NATIONAL
GUARD TO DEPORT THEM, AND THEY
HAVE THEM IN A MILITARY BASE.
>> THERE'S A REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR
UP THERE, RIGHT?
SO I THINK HE WAS PROBABLY
EMPATHETIC TO WHAT THE BORDER
STATES ARE GOING THROUGH, BUT HE
CAN'T GET THE ATTENTION OF THE
WHITE HOUSE.
THE BORDER, THE REPRESENTATIVE
FROM THE BORDER TOWN, HE CAN'T
EVEN GET THE WHITE HOUSE ON THE
PHONE.
SO I THINK ONE OF THE REASONS
THIS IS HAPPENING IS THAT THE
LIBERALS ARE EMBARRASSED,
THEY'RE HUMILIATED, FIGHTING
BACK, AND THEY WANT TO FIGHT
BACK ABOUT PAMPHLETS.
IF THIS IS NOT AN ARGUMENT ABOUT
PAMPHLETS, WHY DIDN'T BIDEN CALL
THE CABINET TOGETHER WHEN YOU
HAD 53 MIGRANTS DIE IN THAT
TRUCK OVERNIGHT?
WHAT ABOUT THE LITTLE GIRLS
WE'VE SEEN, DROPPED OVER THE
WALL, WALKING BY THEMSELVES?
SOME OF THEM DYING.
WHAT ABOUT THAT LESS BOY THAT
DIED?
WHERE'S THE EMERGENCY THEN?
THEY ONLY HAVE AN EMERGENCY NOW?
THAT'S WHY I THINK THE
REPUBLICANS HAVE BEEN
SUCCESSFUL.
NOW, ALL OF THESE PEOPLE, WE
SHOULD CARE ABOUT THEM ALL,
WHETHER THEY'RE AT THE BORDER
TOWN OR THEY'RE IN MARTHA'S
VINEYARD, AND THAT'S WHAT YOU
DON'T SEE YET.
THE LAST THING I'D POINT OUT,
YOU MENTIONED THIS BEFORE, I
CAN'T REMEMBER THE PHRASE YOU
USED, BUT THE STORY IS OUT OF
SIGHT OUT OF MIND IF THE
MEDIA -- IF IT'S NOT HAPPENING
IN THEIR CITY OR IN THEIR OWN
BACKYARD.
SO NOW WE ARE HAVING THE
CONVERSATION, BUT HOW MANY
PEOPLE THIS WEEKEND ALL OF A
SUDDEN WE'RE SEEING EVERYTHING
ABOUT MARTHA'S VINEYARD THAT
DIDN'T KNOW HOW BAD THE MIGRANT
CRISIS WAS?
NOW THEY DO.
>> SO GLAD WE HAD THAT
CONVERSATION.
AREN'T YOU?
>> THE BEST EIGHT MINU